[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
François bonhomme pour le groupe les
républicains monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse au
secrétaire d'État au transport à la mer
et la pêche les transports publics
constituent une cible privilégié nous le
savons tous particulièrement depuis
l'attentat des jouet la tentative
attentat du Talis du 21 août dernier qui
a été miraculeusement déjoué par des
passagers face à ce risque terroriste
qui n'a jamais été aussi fort le
Parlement a adopté une proposition de
loi spécifique visant notamment à
renforcer la sécurité dans les gares et
sur le réseau ferroviaire ce texte
amélioré par le Sénat prévoyait dans sa
version définitive de donner plus de
moyens juridiques et matériel au service
de sécurité des transports publics
j'ajoute que ce texte a pu être examiné
et adopté au terme d'un parcours
législatif très rapide grâce à l'accord
et au rapprochement des deux chambres il
a été promulgué le 22 mars dernier or 4
mois après les différentes mesures
d'application sont restées lettrre
mortes c'est donc le statut quo en
particulier pour le décret visant à
réaliser un contrôle des candidats au
postes sensibles en lien avec la
sécurité notamment au sein de la RATP et
de la SNCF ou encore le décret visant à
leur donner la possibilité nouvelle de
procéder à des inspections visuelles ou
à des fouilles de bagages qui n'a
toujours pas été
pris de même le décret d'application
donant la possibilité à ces 4000
d'être dispensé du port de tenue
c'est-à-dire en fait du droit de
circuler dans les rames ou locomotive
sur les qua en civil qui fait toujours
défaut vous comprendrez monsieur le
ministre que cela de quoi étonner c'est
pourquoi je souhaiterais que vous nous
donniez et nous indiquiez les raisons de
ce retard constaté dans les publications
des décrets
d'application pour vous répondre à la
parole monsieur al vid secrétaire d'État
en charge des transports monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur François bonhomme
vous évoquez les l'application de la loi
sur la sécurité dans les transports dont
vous étiez le rapporteur devant le Sénat
ce texte a été promulgué le 22 mars
dernier il faut distinguer naturellement
les dispositions d'application immédiate
de Cell nécessitant des décrets
d'application beaucoup de mesures
importantes sont d'application immédiate
je le rappelle vous ne l'avez pas fait
les agents du service interne de
sécurité de la SNCF et de la RATP
peuvent depuis le 22 mars procéder à
l'inspection visuelle et à la fouille
des bagages n pas besoin de texte
d'abication dans le cadre des
réquisitions judiciaires les officiers
de police judiciaire peuvent procéder à
des contrôles d'identité mais également
à l'inspection visuelle des bagages ou à
leur fouille dans les véhicules et les
emprises immobilières des transports
publics pas besoin de décret
d'application les policiers municipaux
et ça va intéresser beaucoup les
policiers municipaux peuvent constater
par procès verbaux les infractions à la
police du transport comme je reçois
beaucoup de courriers de maire qui me
demandent le décret d'application je
précise ici clairement au nom du
gouvernement aucune disposition
d'application n'est nécessaire pour le
maire sur le territoire de sa commune
cette disposition est d'application
immédiate je pense que cette information
était attendue concernant les mesures
qui nécessitent des textes d'application
le décret d'application relative aux
palpations de sécurité ou encore à la
dispense de tenue que vous avez évoqué
est actuellement examiné vous
conviendrez que le gouvernement n'a pas
de mesure il est devant le Conseil
d'État dès que le conseil de texte
existe le gouvernement a fini son
travail nous attendons la réponse la
même chose en ce qui concerne le contenu
et la formation des agents de la suus
même chose en ce qui concerne
l'exploitation des service de transport
des données d'information vous savez que
c'était un débat que nous avons eu la
même chose nous attend end la réponse de
l'acnil en ce qui concerne les le port
de la tenue je crois que ces mesures
doivent être rappelées cette loi a été
importante et le gouvernement est très
attaché à ce qu'elle soit mise en œuvre
le plus rapidement possible Monsieur
Bonhomme monsieur le ministre j'entends
ce que vous me dites mais je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de penser que vous esquissez
quelques contortionnement car les
mesures qui restent à à à prendre par
décret sont excessivement importantes et
il ne faudrait pas dans le contexte que
nous connaissons que l'arbre de de la
bonne l'organisation de l'uro cache la
forêt du risque terroriste qui demeure
omniprésent et permanent
merci